Ernie Johnson Curtis Granderson Jimmy
Rollins and Pedro Martinez all it took
was one explosive inning for the Diamond
Backs to get this done this time I mean
it
was it was crazy and I love the way Tori
said I was sitting back saying the same
thing everybody in the studio was saying
like what is happening we have never
seen this and we talked about it before
the show that they believe in themselves
and that what and that is what matters
the most they kept pressing they kept
pressing L talked about it before the
season ended how he gives up home runs
and Arizona made sure that came true
tonight and it was crazy we talked about
how just statistically in the season
they were average in home runs they
showed tonight not only can they hit
them but they can keep hitting them and
keep hitting them and want to go f they
can hit another one I mean it was
amazing to see they just get hot get
confident and continue to kept doing
what they were doing listen I will we
always during the entire time we have
been following this team we we always
always keep saying spe the unexpected
spe the unexpected as much baseball as
we all have seen we have never seen
anything like it and and I'm glad in a
positive way this has been a really fun
postseason but man you have to also give
credit a lot of credit to Mike hayon and
Tor
lulo what I saw today from Tor lulo with
that youngster that he has on the mound
today on the Clincher I mean made me
shake my head because I I don't know how
he structured that plan but everything
played right for him and everything he
did was the right move that he had to
make and he pulled the young kid in the
fourth inning even though he had a four
nothing lead he pulled the kid after
giving up a double and went right back
to his Bullpen and used them accordingly
and you can see the results but four
homers all the weird things that
happened the dodg not being able to hit
I guess that sitting down really really
did affect them second straight year the
Dodgers get bounced in the National
League Division Series and suddenly we
only have one Division Series still in
play and we will have game four of that
series tomorrow night right here on TBS
we're going to hit the air at 7:00 bring
you an hourong pregame show and then the
Braves and the Phillies with
Philadelphia trying to put away the
Braves leading that series two gamees to
one meantime on the Arizona side Lauren
shahadi had a chance to speak with
Corbin
Carroll Carvin Carol congratulations
you're going into NLCS as a rookie of
the year how does that
sound you know this is this is what we
worked all year for um it's amazing to
be here it's it doesn't feel real I mean
a 412 average in the postseason it's not
supposed to be that easy how has your
first postseason compared to what you
thought it would
be yeah you know uh just trying to stay
St in the moment not make it bigger than
what it is um you know same game just
take it day at a time pitch at a time I
keep hearing Corbin they didn't think we
belonged here they didn't think we'd
make it here what's your reaction to
this and what do you want to say to them
let's keep going let's keep proving them
wrong good luck thank
you thanks to Corbin Carrol for spending
that time with Lauren shahadi meantime
we've talked about the the third inning
of this game when all four Diamondback
runs were scored all with the long ball
let's take a look at it guys and U it
begins with a number nine hitter a Domo
guy that hasn't been hitting anything
whatsoever comes up with a homer and
lights up I mean the entire Stadium I
mean down to one knee when you throwing
pitches down the middle they get hit
there's no movement they're flat coming
into the Zone there's nothing to fool
them with he didn't miss a barrel that
in it yeah after a ground out catel
Marte delivers into the seats w stand up
on them let them know something did we
mention that Lance Lynn gave up the most
homers in The Bigs this year at 44 and
there is Christian Walker but Jimmy you
talk about down the middle I mean they
have that Strike Zone box on the TV all
four of these are in the middle of the
box that's where hitters like to hit
them I Manan a sweet spot middle in
middle middle the way uh knee high to
the Belt those are very hitable pitches
even if you have vo those are hitable
pitches Lance l doesn't have v he's not
getting the ball by it was very
important for him to hit corners and
change location he wasn't doing that he
was just moving across the plate and
these batters made to be honest Jimmy in
the first two innings he did it I I
thought respectfully well but then I
don't know if it was that it got into a
routine of just going through the
motions and everything was just flat the
breaking balls the fast ball everything
was coming back to the middle or maybe
he ran out of gas I don't know what
happened but man uh I thought he was
going to have a better game than he
first two WIS yeah after the first
Innings I kept saying they have to get
depth out of their starter they don't
get depth out of their starter that's a
bad thing because that means you're
down and you mentioned Brandon fought um
who got the start today for Arizona goes
four and a third allows just two hits no
runs struck out a couple and this a guy
who went two and two3 in the wild card
game but man did he answer the Bell
tonight and I think part of it is when
you have that young and and not
necessarily the playoff experience you
have excitement you have energy you're
getting a chance to go back at home to a
crowd that you said hadn't seen them
since the regular season in it but not
only that they hadn't seen him in the
playoffs for a long time there's a
certain level of confidence and energy
you get when they give you the ball in
that situation you haven't known
anything different let me just go out
there and execute my game let me do it
I'm coming off with a two lead already
my team is playing well let me just do
what I need to do and not try to do too
much couple of things Stu out once you
had the 4 nothing lead I thought it was
a danger zone when Arizona left the
Bases Loaded in the fifth inning uh
because that still gives the Dodgers a
window they score a couple but I think
their series was encapsulated in the uh
top of the eighth inning you get a
leadoff walk and then you've got the
tying run at the plate Mookie Betts and
Freddy Freeman and both strike out it is
weird I mean I've never seen anything
like it and I did not expect it from
Dodgers not even today coming into the
game today I thought the Dodgers have at
least one win in them uh or or or go
differently about you know the game and
and what they were trying to do and even
when Lance Lynn held the Arizona Diamond
Back to a third inning I I thought they
were going to have better quality at
bats and it it didn't show it didn't
really show that they were having better
at bats they never look comfortable and
what really surprises me is to see
Freddy Freeman and
mooki not look as competitive as they
were I guess that sitting down really
affected especially those two guys
because the they have us all accustomed
to seeing better at bats more aggressive
at bats better pitches selection and
this time it didn't show and it was from
top to bottom everybody was just except
for maybe Smith now Will Smith swung a
good bat yeah he was he was having
pretty good at bats but everybody else
was just Stone Cold mookie bets 0 for 11
in the series three for his last 38 over
his last 10 postseason games um Freddy
Freeman one for 10 in the series explain
that to me hey I wish we could that's
the one thing we're trying to figure out
when you had had this many days off
everyone goes is it really that
important the answer is I mean the proof
is in the pudding we've seen it happen
for a number of different teams the
puzzling question is how do you get
yourself out of it how do you do
something different you try to go ahead
and simulate practice being out there
with batting practice getting more reps
on the te getting on the field simulated
games but nothing matches like actually
being in the game being out there for
the hours getting there for BP getting
there for the game a three hour game a 4
Hour game 50,000 people in the stands
you can't practice that and once you
have day after day day after day day
after day off sometimes you start to
lose that feel and lose that Rhythm
these are two of the best hitters that
are in the MVP category and all of a
sudden they got Stone Cold Dodgers get
swept Orioles get swept Braves on the
ropes against Philadelphia only Houston
out of those teams that advanced to the
DS didn't have to play in the Wild Card
they're the only ones yeah but those are
are the teams that kept rolling they had
to battle their way yeah he all to the
last day yeah up to the last day and
they they just continue to play so th
those are the teams that probably took
advantage of you know continue to play
can't wait to see who the nominees are
for the who's your daddy poll on this uh
on this night uh we love to see who the
fans the unexpected fans like Bryce
Harper they like Aon Nola think where
you Landing pet oh boy
yeah I got you play
jion I got you and oh look at a a
manager Tory lello getting some getting
some love oh he needs some love he's
done and his attitude has just went
throughout that Clubhouse we saw him
early in the year you know getting into
almost seemingly physical fights and his
team bagged him up it's like this is who
we are we're Fighters we're the scrappy
little brothers to the Dodgers to the
Padre's and that's fine we'll take that
roll on and I I think I know where you
going player I'm going to follow the
pool today I promise you today is
different expect the unexpected I'm I'm
following the pool today exactly we
expect you to be I'm following the pool
today don't worry my daddy with some
gray right there that'd be a perfect
daddy we will